oh yeah so this match is part of a
series
it's a series of matches between
chicago players and texas players
there's already been a lot of matches so
far uh the overall score is
based on total number of points from
each side
so the current score is actually really
close texas is up
128 and a half to 123 and a half chicago
trailing by
five points so i guess there's pressure
on me to perform well
i am representing chicago originally
from the chicago area
currently in st louis but chicago is not
too far away
but we'll play some london's we'll see
how it goes
let me just play the straightforward
lines and then we can see what we'll do
i feel like i should turn the author off
that white's for choice sorry yasser
how big it is i i think it's okay
not that uh let's play d5
okay i'm i'm not going to look at chat
i'll probably close chat
and turn off alerts let's play a6 here's
that's so important to not move too
slowly let's play bishop b7
so we have a more solid like queen's
gambit declined castle here
um i don't think there's any need to
play c6 right away
more interested in playing rookie 8
yeah rookie 8 because there's cases
where if white castle is queen side i
want to play c5 in one move
um yeah let me turn off alerts i do
appreciate people who've been subbing
thank you stephen gray
i'm hiding chat i might like look at
chat between games but
i'll try and have full focus here
um yeah h3 is playable so i play knight
here just reinforcing the pawn because
of this battery
uh very often like g6 can happen
um
[Music]
yeah usually i i play c6 earlier but i
still don't think there's a huge reason
probably next move like the plan here is
to play c6
uh bishop d6 and then h6 and then
basically
force a trade of bishop for knight
um yeah this is actually still
some kind of preparation i usually have
this position without the pawn on h3 but
it's similar
so if a4 which is a typical minority
attack
uh then i'll play this this this and
i'll be threatening to take here because
the
pawn on g2 will be overworked so this is
now a big threat
so h3 maybe wasn't the most accurate
because it gives me a target
uh knight d2 is natural looking but it
leaves the king side kind of naked
i also have a nice lead in time here an
h4 like so knight d2 knight h4 is
a nice sort of idea
okay nice time advantage up a minute
i mean this is still basically opening
preparation
um just the move order was tricky
because my opponent
uh like when i played a6 on move what
was it move
three move four um
it was a bit bit tricky to navigate the
nuances
so knight h2 it's interesting queen g5
comes from mine knight h4
in the h4
not even giving white the option of
trying to simplify
targeting this and there's already
things blooming of maybe sacking and
mating
someday or dirty flagging
i'm going to try and win this game on
like on the position
and maybe on the clock too
and this goes to show like why opening
preparation
is so so important especially in blitz
it's like most of the scheme is just
kind of relying on memory rather than
having to figure things out
and there's no increment uh so queen g5
i can take some time here i'm also
calculating this this
uh takes takes queen f3 rook g1
not quite working
i have a bad habit of when my point gets
on time i'll start moving slower so
i'm gonna try and address that here
the time of anders is just too great
queen here probably
i should note the queen defends g2
now e3 is weak two attackers there's no
wreck of three because i take
okay that's a good sign
i'm looking for the knockout blow i'm
wondering if i can take on
i just sack
and there's g5 too
[Music]
if it doesn't work i'll win on time the
g5 is kind of cool
yeah or trade or not
free bishop but then lose a knight
um i guess white survived kind of
but still a nice position i'll win a
rook
okay that was nice okay so not really
any breaks
i'll play a london i have to dedicate
this one to
andrea um
i i do have an idea of what we'll go
into i think he's going to take him
bishop f5 or queen b6 interesting
so this is carlson aronian from some
year
it's a more positional line
um i'll admit i'm not so well prepared
here
i have a feeling my opponent is much
more prepared
uh i should know what i'm doing
let's play c3 a5 my kong queen c1
i might play bishop d3 and just kind of
neutralize the tension
[Music]
actually a5 can be met with a4
play bishop e2
or h3 now let's get the king safe
it's important not to spend too much
time here
it's kind of developed normally maybe
now h3
give the bishop a pocket
yeah i'll only dedicate this one to
andrea if i win but we have very typical
like
london middle game um
it's kind of a reverse structure of what
we had the first game this is like a
carl's bad structure
black might have the eventual minority
attack idea i probably want to trade
bishops
another reason for each three preventing
this move
now upon time yeah so 94 and just kind
of have to deal with it
uh rookie 2 is natural i might play
knight d2 as well
[Music]
just challenge the knight f5 can
probably be met with f3
take with queen probably
so there's a typical positional idea if
we do trade in black plays a5
very often the knight is best placed on
d3
um it's called the kappa blanca knight
so knight t1 knight d3 is uh
the plan to access the juicy or dark
squares
i might start with this immediately
this comes from kind of my experience
playing queen's gamut decline too
just having the structure knight also
defends b2
so b2 is defended
[Music]
doing well with time might want to go
for the attack
like similar to last game have a target
up about a minute might end up playing
rook b1
just to over defend the pawn so i can
mobilize a queen
there's this tricky move too to threaten
to take
i don't think e5 is a big threat so i'll
start with rook b1
yeah i have a lot of things covering e5
queen f3 queen g4
i'm being a bit more direct i'm gonna
try and make some gradual improvements
there's a baby crying in the distance
but i don't think people hear because
the mic is
sound settings are good it's kind of
distracting for me though
bishop g3
okay let's just keep up the pace i want
to play h4 the h4 h5
is another gradual way to improve
okay we'll double up the rooks nothing
too special
and the queen is a little bit misplaced
we put the bishop on g5
f3 is legal maybe this move
f6 can i take probably not
the bishop might go all the way back
ooh
there's queen e3
i mean we could trade let's trade in 95
some ideas of delving in maybe i'll feed
kalo my queen
and put the nylon g5
some idea of sacking
uh yeah the play is a bit easier for
black
can i sack
it looks so much fun if it doesn't work
i'd probably win on
time let's play this first nail sack
so i calculated this idea
again i don't know if it works but it's
there's a lot of pressure here and i'm
winning the queen now
this would be a bad premium because g5
was possible
[Music]
okay so that worked out nicely oh i
could have taken a rook
okay one on time let's go nice start
e4 i gotta play one stafford right
oh no stafford have a bishop oh he plays
this opening
um don't know any theory here
how do the pieces move again
i have no idea what i'm doing this is
like urasov jonathan tron's
magical thing i assume this is a
variation okay
i kind of know what i'm doing bishop c5
or bishop e7
i think both moves are playable
yeah it's been ages since i've studied
this i used to kind of play this as
white
in certain lines i blunder
knight is fine if this i take with check
this is all still kind of typical
[Music]
um and taking
taking is legal f5 is an option maybe
i'll play f5
but then e6
this looks okay
i'm just trying to get an easy position
to play or easier position to play
i remember some trap like f6 or some
there's some crazy like rook f8 sack
line
to remember that game
have like very hazy memories of this
variation
okay so here i could take with the queen
i guess the knight's probably going to
come in
so the pawn structure is hideous but i
do have the bishop hair
so it's kind of the imbalance of worse
palm structure but
better minor piece pair
position is kind of opening up too i
have a pass pawn
which could very easily turn into a
strength
this c6 pawn is defended currently
uh queen b3 is okay just king h8
so i probably want to play like bishop
b6 maybe eventually c5 kick away the
knight
that's logical white just wants to trade
let's avoid the trade i'm allowing this
but then queen f7 c5
i mean white might do oh this and this
runs into c5 anyway
probably don't want to trade queens but
then i lose a pawn
so maybe i do want to trade queens
actually not entirely sure here
so indecisive
i guess we'll trade queens in a5
[Music]
i'm not sure how to evaluate this
there's some nice pressure now
a4 can't be played and a4 is coming from
me
may have been a mistake though
okay so opposite card bishop situation
i'm probably a little bit worse here but
all three results are possible
[Music]
i'll put the bishop in
a2 is a target so the rook's kind of
tied down this move
no that doesn't work
oh what to do i could put the bishop on
d3
it looks currently tied down to b2 so
there's no rook d7
yeah bishop d3 is nice
rook could be five maybe
but before i on passant and i want to
double up because the pawn is
pawn is kind of backwards here
i might be oh no i'm not winning upon
forgot about bishop a3
so c5 maybe just going for the
the uh the trapping of the bishop kind
of put the king on a better square
not entirely sure what to do i'm just
reinforcing my bishop opening the fifth
rank maybe h5 ideas
undermine the structure play rook e5
i still want to play h5 that's like the
one way to make progress
h5 looks risky because like things are
opening up against the king but i think
it's okay
so i just want to take and do this
rook g2 is probably the move to play
there's almost some meeting ideas
oh wow wait am i in trouble
oh no i'm not in trouble i just take
it's weird though
probably keep brooks on the board
up a decent amount of time here
um let's play this move go for e3
[Music]
still going for eventually e3 when upon
now the pawn just wants to run like the
wind
and now it's uh now it's winning
a cool end game okay that was definitely
probably the closest game so far
opposite car bishop situation okay i'll
play e4
seemed like my point was prepared for
london a little bit
um i know they're prepared for ponziani
too
so i don't i was showing ponziani on the
stream earlier
uh i'll play i'll play four knights
e3 how loud that's kind of a cool line
and then we'll go into this trickiness
yeah it's a very rare variation
i think it's objectively equal but um
it's not a bad weapon for blitz because
it's not so easy to
to figure out for black
so the point i should explain i'm
sacking a piece
um but then after queen e2 i'm
guaranteed to win it back
and there's variations where i just go
up a pawn like queenie
ii knight takes knight i take and then
i'll be up upon
and a3 is actually it's important to
like have this
if we compare this to a four night
scotch if the pawn was still here
there's takes here f6 d4 bishop b4
it's hard to explain this with arrows
but um
i guess the point i'm trying to make is
a3 prevents bishop b4 in
certain variations
yeah it's so nice to to play six moves
with prep and then
be up a minute on the clock
now i think there's some reason why this
is objectively not great for white
but honestly i don't even remember it
like there's some move back in play here
if the pawn was still here f6 is the
best move
but f6 here d4 i think it's still a fine
position
yeah so this is a line where i'm just uh
i take
i guess there's bishop f6
so all taken bishop here yeah i'm just
up a pawn
[Music]
i mean the pawns are doubled so maybe
it's
kind of like i'm up half a pawn but
it's still very pleasant very solid
rook d1 looks natural
always have to be careful like when the
rooks align with the queen
so bishop d6 will play queen h5
i'm a little bit slow to castle but i
think the king is relatively safe
yeah i mean from black's perspective
they want to probably
try and prevent me from casting but um
this or this will come with
tempo you have to play this move
yeah i mean the time time kind of tells
the story here
so i can't play bishop z4 i'll hang a
bishop this is a threat
probably h3
oh h3 bishop c5 that's actually tricky
so maybe bishop e2
so blocking the pin also preventing
bishop g4
just a safe move i could win another
pawn but then lose this pawn
i can't castle maybe rook d4
to attack the queen
now i can castle and put the queen on
each three
so just keeping things defended we're
both trying to attack on the king's side
now
but i'm trying to win on time too i play
queen h6
uh there's rook h42 which looks
really enticing
[Music]
i didn't see that oh but i open that
file
that's a cool line
um okay i'm just trying to be precise
here
queen
maybe this move this is actually a cool
move because queen or bishop takes i
have this or this
this is mate okay
that was nice there's another a nice bit
of opening preparation
i think i'll play a budapest
feeling confident
okay going into main line take a pawn
so the idea is this and this and this
and then this and this
okay so trying to it's a nice kind of
variety so far of openings
unleashing a lot of tricky lines
meanwhite has various options i think
the two most common moves are
yeah a3 or b3
so one reason for playing rookie is to
give the bishop the square to move back
ah so white sees the plan i'll play d5
here
on personal recapture
and the rook probably won't develop this
way
but maybe i'll still get like a solid
also aggressive position um
i think bishop f5
i didn't want to play this too soon is
knight knight b6
i mean maybe now c6 just kind of
solidifying
knight b6 i play rook b8 and lights not
too not doing too much damage from b6
and the bishop always covers g7s the
knight's not actually pinned
i want to play this or this but neither
move really works
i could play queen c7
just kind of reinforcing the knight want
to put the rook on d8
okay probably bishop oh knight's kind of
pinned now
bishop e4 is a legal move
and this looks solid white can't really
add another attacker to the knight
just yet f6 if necessary
yeah probably f6 not the most appealing
move
but it's a move
but the rook back
time is closer to this game so now here
i play rook there
and the bishops get skewered knight c3
hmm
i didn't actually oh queen d4 okay
there weren't too many ways to defend
there
um actually my rook is a bit stuck
play bishop f5
i want to bring the queen in
okay we have to trade i feel like i'm
getting outplayed this game
i'm still a fight though i want to bring
the queen here
put the bishop here
ah there's bishop d3 too
if f3 i'll play bishop d3
there's also knight g6 but this
should be five
if i i mean if takes i'm happy with the
fork
put the bishop on a6 randomly as a weird
square but at least it does something it
blocks the rook from coming in
keeping some time advantage
[Music]
i feel still a little bit squeezed
play queen c7 just go for some
simplification
i want to put the pawns on probably
light squares
trade rook g1 bishop h6
bishop should probably be like it
doesn't want to move though because
um because rook comes in now it can
maybe move
oh there's a funny idea ricko's
nevermind let's swing the rook this way
yeah there is a funny idea i'm allowing
rook a7 to then hug the rook with my
bishop and pawn
i can take in rookie two it's not
plunderer rook
yeah rook is now hugged kind of there's
rook 8
oh i didn't see that that's a good move
uh i'm in trouble
dirty flag maybe
wow
hey it's a dirty flag draw
oh i feel really dirty but that's what
hand sanitizer is for
[Music]
oh okay that's the first draw so no no
adoption i guess
let's play another one of these only
crazy game
oh thanks for selling monkey library
i i i thought i was going to flag there
opponent was really fast
that's why time is so important okay
we're gonna
keep moving on um
i'm playing in spanish for some reason
do i even play the spanish
so b5 is the main line
okay so we're going into main line kind
of spanish
the main line main main line is h3 but
this is a cool variation
um
[Music]
i'm trying to remember prep like there's
very specific preparation here
i think after i think h3
is timely there's a really cool idea
knight d2 queen d2 bishop f3
and then queen c3
um also i'm allowing this but it's all
okay because queen c2
like there's some exchange stack line
this is actually one of the reasons why
i play the spanish is for this specific
variation
i think there is some game uh pono mario
of
pono mario vallyanov pretty sure
ponomari have had this position
at some point i remember
actually a few years ago i played the
over the board tournament
the philly open in the last round i was
sitting next to
andrew tang playing jeffrey zhang
and jeffrey unleashed this move against
andrew
and won in like 10 more moves from this
position
[Music]
um then like a year later i played this
line
in vegas against christian carrillo
and got a good position but he held on
for a draw
but it's nice preparation just to blitz
out
uh and the point is i'm attacking the
knight and
um like some of the lines are based on
like engine ideas
so i'll have to remember what i'm doing
i think i can take takes and then
and there's always a prospect of bishop
b4
uh so oh yeah rook i think rook here
is coming back to memory rook ec1
avoiding the skewer leaving the knight
and bishop still attacked
it's like really cool opening crap
i don't know if i've actually had this
queen c3 idea
ever on stream like one of these
openings i've i've
used once over the board
i did show a recent youtube video i was
sharing
some of my preparation with sagar shaw
um oh am i in trouble here
takes take i mean i have to take the
bishop
i guess i take the bishop in bishop f4
i may have gone wrong already because i
don't remember this situation
but i have to i mean i could pl a3 is
another move actually
a3 is a funny move
a3
because the problem is a c file
[Music]
i think i play three here
insisting that i don't want the queen to
come in
so for last so many moves and light and
bishop have still been hanging
that's a great way to like vacuum away
opponents time
uh this is one of the issues sometimes
with preparing openings is
you rely too much on the on remembering
and then you forget
you don't understand what's going on
okay let's take and
the bishop's still attacked yeah that's
the move so i have this
i have to play g3
this is kind of backfiring actually
hopefully it's still okay
bishop f4
our time is becoming more relevant so i
unleash the queen so this doesn't work
g5 i have to move back to d2 that's an
interesting move
and there's g4 here so many counter
attacks
oh g4 queen h3 okay let's move this way
c file's still uh a weapon for me
wow
crazy move
um yeah let's simplify
keeping some time advantage
[Music]
go after the d-pawn
i should win on time
free bishop hey it's mate what was mate
i was just excited i could take a pawn
with chuck okay
that was cool i was actually turned into
like a hard fight
i'll have to check the theory later with
that line
um okay if he plays bishop z4 i'll play
oh let's play a stafford
okay stafford gambit time my opponent's
probably prepared
i should have saved this for the bullet
uh i might just get punished from
it's good they're taking time though
maybe not super well prepared
thanks for subbing i i'm not seeing chat
but i see uh the sub alerts
vanu men and biscu and al dinero
and mikhail balakirev appreciate all the
the love and support
so we're going into the jonathan trunks
magical line of
stockfish greatness
again every time i play this line i have
to give jonathan a shout out
because he basically innovated this
whole concept
and managed to to draw the highest level
of stockfish on the chest
from this position as black
but in that game g3 was played
this is another playable line
white subject will be better but there's
some some center pressure
i have the time advantage which is nice
uh oh and i might get a pawn cube the
indestructible pawn cube
hopefully
ooh that castling's probably
completely fine so now it's a question
what to do probably just worse
i mean f5 is legal maybe i should have
put the bishop elsewhere
maybe i can provoke white to
cubify my pawns let's go
home sweet home also this is a target i
want to move the bishop somewhere like
bishop b3
i could play f5 too it's kind of
interesting
i'm thinking f5 here and then get the
bishop on a nice diagonal
and again i'm objectively worse i just
lose a pawn
i didn't realize that was just hanging
okay so i gambled upon
i have to treat every blunder as a
gambit
uh that's a really good move to play
this maybe
but there's still like weird
compensation
it's a thing when like playing the
staffer like you got the worst position
but lingering ideas and i have the pawn
cube
uh probably this move and
fight for that file
okay i'm probably meaning too much i
should
focus on playing reasonable moves that's
actually a really strong move
trying to destroy my pawn cube
i wonder can i it's so risky
but a6 and then king b7
this is so risky the cube has turned
into one of those
tetris pieces
so a7 the king goes to b7 i barely
blockade the pawn
but it does look really risky
[Music]
but if i don't lose immediately maybe
i'll i'll survive
oh rook e5
rhyming with my last word
um i mean queen f7 probably
the queen side down to f2 up a little
bit of time here
this pawn can be a huge strength or just
an easy
weakness like free food
game so far
okay let's snack on a pawn
ah my pawns are gonna be in
slightly more shambles
hey triple pawns i'm one capture away
from quadruple pawns
also opponent wants to sneakily do
things on the a file
[Music]
i mean i think it's okay though
hopefully
point a three issue is rook here and
then here
i'll just go for counter play i'm
covering the square which is nice
offer the queen trade take a free queen
yeah no mercy kind of upset i didn't get
quadruple pawns but
okay oh that was a
that was a very meme worthy game um
let's play another one of these
i'm expecting my opponent to play like
sicilian or kerokana
oh
um novelty
i mean let's repeat i guess i'll just
repeat the same opening
it works kind of well
[Music]
i mean my opponent maybe knows what's
coming here
d5
i know this is objectively good for
white oh playing this line
so this is also objectively good for
white apparently
after queen c2
oh ooh
opponent did their homework i wonder
rook
probably rook c1
i mean all i know is engine gives a plus
after bishop b4
but last time i looked at this was
probably like a year ago
[Music]
or no i looked at this kind of before
sagar shah's match or the match with
sagar shah i forget if i looked at this
specifically
yeah it's a weird position because
there's always lingering ideas of taking
queen side pieces are sidelined
bishop's out of play knight c4 are very
respectable
i want to be accurate i know this one's
coming
i mean king h2 is just so natural
idea to play rook g1 just use the g
file like we're going to get a situation
probably where we're both trying to
attack on the king side
down a little bit of time
but position is looking really nice
because rook ag-1 is coming
and how to make progress i want to trap
the queen
like f4 maybe
f5 is a clear idea we might see fi from
black
but then there's there's weird like
bishop d1 ideas
there's pawn diamond potential
[Music]
man we got a pawn cube followed by a
pawn diamond
back to back games
okay let's stay focused this move
king h8 respectable
maybe queen e2 the queen e2 f5
spending way too much time here
queen c3 so ideas just bishop here the
queen looks weird
on c3 but it's just it's just getting
out the way
i probably don't want to on passant put
the rook back
queen e2 i might have to play queen c2
[Music]
yeah i'm not super thrilled here maybe
i'll end up taking
[Music]
interesting we'll start with oh now i
have to play this
cuz i was threatening to take with check
okay so i want to play b3 and provoke
the pawn diamond
provoke the knight to diamond defy my
pawns
ah okay this is fine though c file
a c pawn is backwards
maybe queen c6 coming
yeah i'm gonna play very positionally
here
up on time for the first time in a while
yeah now it's really easy i kind of
weathered the storm a tricky position
earlier
okay
uh it's kind of tricky move oh i can
be tricky too tactics
so i'm just kind of winning a pawn or
two
[Music]
yeah not quite a diamond
oh this is kind of a diamond
oh wow i blunder i blundered
oh no okay i have this move thankfully
i was almost a tragic disaster
i can pre-move on the light squares
okay that was tricky though kudos to my
opponent for
being being devious there
okay so we have three more games of
of three minutes
okay so i'm repeating the same line i
think we played this in the first game
so my opponent kind of knows what to
expect
that pawn's defended if takes i take
back still defending the pawn
oh g4 okay so this is probably a case
where i go for some
[Music]
earlier c5 i might play b5 first
so i don't want to play h6 because that
gives black or gives white a target to
try and open up files very likely white
will castle
king side or a queen side but okay i
guess not
rook c1
so i want to play in the center somehow
i might play bishop b7 actually
multi-purpose preparing this and
preparing this and this
like one of the problems for white in
this sort of position is a king if the
center opens up the king might not have
a safe place
so the goals yeah the goal is some
combination of c5 94
i forgot about that move thankfully i
have this move
you might end up trading
that's sharp though oh i'm just losing a
pawn
i'm just losing a pawn unfortunately i
mean it's still sharp
i guess yeah bishop f5 i guess won a
pawn maybe i should have moved the rook
but then i lose e7
well played okay i'm not gonna calculate
just relying on intuition the main idea
i see is if
pawn ever takes i play this and bishop
becomes a monster
oh maybe i should have calculated
i think it's okay though because if
knight takes hers there's takes takes
and with a pin
so there's x-ray vision in both
directions i'm threatening the knight
and the fork
i am down two pawns but
i have the bishop here yeah this is a
fun position
two pawn gambit
slightly unintentional
don't entirely see like knight e g yeah
knight eg1 is maybe the
the sad move then i take
if again it takes i have choice which
material to grab the king is still very
safe
um
there's a really funny line here i don't
think it works so i want to take and
play this and this
the problem is rook to you mark d1 a5
knight c3 we trade
i could also just take immediately
bishop b4 is a move
i do have time here ponder the
possibilities
um man there's a lot of like fun looking
moves
g6 might be g6 looks weakening though
there's a funny move queen d5
i think i'll play it because
just ensures king's safety like if we
trade queens
white still has all the same problems
um this is probably not the best move
but just a practical decision
because now if check i take and there's
more pressure on the diagonal
i guess there is a line like knight
takes takes pawn takes
a lot of things could get traded
oh knight takes i just take with bishop
yeah there's kind of a double pin
also thanks for the bits i wear shoes
oh uh
oh there's a cool there's a funny line
rook takes c6
oh no my queen but then i'll take back
and there's still the double pin
okay so now i win the rook
anything better
um i'm just trying to be precise here
now
probably just defend this way queen
defends the bishop
it's guarding the back rank
go for bishop c4
okay opponent resigned yeah okay time
was good
that was a cool game got sharp
in the middle game uh i'll probably mix
up the opening of e5
yeah so opponents being consistent
um i'm running out of things to play
i can play a halloween i'll play
halloween
why not opponent might get back the
piece
or not wait what's the line again
pawn here
i mess up the line i messed up the line
it was pawn d5
yeah okay i'm down a piece
halloween gambit
oh opponent kind of knows what they're
doing too i think d5 is like the best
move
these sort of positions but queen f3 may
be coming
actually i don't know if d5 was the best
move there there's another line where d5
makes sense but i think it's when you
can play c6
maybe with a knight on g6
okay oh maybe this is still good for
black
i don't know
oh why am i putting myself in this
situation
[Music]
take some bishop e3 maybe i pretty much
have to take
so i'm throwing kind of d5 not really
i do have two pawns for the piece so
there's something
to work with basically going for more
kind of long-term compensation
[Music]
yeah a good move
so i just want to use the pawns
this is my halloween costume
such a bad costume
um hi maybe queen d3
so some queen b5 idea some c4 idea
yeah so now there's rook b5 and takes b7
his
potential ideas the problem is queen c4
a queen c4 d5 like imagine b6 rook b5
queen c4 d5
it's kind of interesting i think it
still kind of works here
i didn't even consider taking the pawn
probably because like this move
oh it's getting weird now
what is this i should probably just push
and pray
rook d8 c4 oh there's bishop f5 too
it's it's interesting like i have my
pawns controlling center
and this is what the halloween is all
about
pretending to be scary
uh c2 is weak
so let's retreat
i'm probably going to loosey to it
somewhere kind of take a pawn
[Music]
that's getting weird
it's already weird d6
rt1 probably rt1
[Music]
problem is bishop g4
maybe d6 yeah
spending too much time
okay there's a weird line bishop g4 d6
was just calculating not sure but
looks interesting
gotta go for this so there's some pin
[Music]
i probably want to play h3 when i have
the chance
i also have night moves i take on c7
have some nice pawn chain
one move away from winning connect five
the g3 is not not a move i want to play
oh knight d knight d5 i take on c7
[Music]
okay let's take this way
knight c4 queen d5 with a pin from
behind and attacking this
okay so i'm threatening made in two and
okay hey
it's a halloween miracle
uh okay so one more game
one more game and then we take a half
time break
maybe i'll play stafford again or not
okay i'm preventing those d4
shenanigans so we'll play an italian
oh this line ah what is this line
bishop d4 it's bishop d4
this is a i think they call it the
deutsch gambit
see how booked up my opponent is so f4
is uh the main idea
i was commentating a match between
nicola steudson
twitch streamer and sergey karjakin
and they went into this line but i don't
remember like karyakum was black and
unleashed some cool preparation
but i forgot all of it
i vaguely remember some rook g8 move
like larry kaufman novelty
oh it's been so long maybe h6 first
i mean bishop v6 looks natural
[Music]
or queenie seven i have no idea what i'm
doing here
i want to use a square some pieces
the pins annoying i am temporarily up
upon
[Music]
preventing this we might still be in
theory actually
guess i had queen c5 ideas as well
[Music]
okay i mean things are covered
i know there's some line where rook g8
is played with a pawn still here where
you anticipate the g-file opening
we might get a structure where the
g-file opens and king just kind of
chills in the center
wait free bishop i think
opponent just forgot
or maybe played the wrong move in the
calculation
[Music]
probably had to take okay so i think
it's a half time break
so open up chats that was nice that was
12 moves
trying to show no mercy this is a team
match so every game counts
every point counts for the team i think
we were trailing by
five points before before these games so
now we're up by five
but we still have 11 more games to play
so this is bullet it is sometimes hard
to adjust between
blitz and bullets but c3 c3
okay we'll play this
uh i'll play a5 we have a reverse
old indian kind of black lion i don't
know what we call this
i'm gonna put the queen on a7 attack
upon
it's playable queen defends
queen is doing weird things i want to
play this move
you're threatening this now and this
and i'm going to win f2 and then too wow
i want all the material just go for the
queen trade
okay no mercy
simplify more
[Music]
i'm just trying to provoke resignation
i'll play g6 just preventing that f5
no oh that was a mouse slip ah it's
still winning but that's annoying
i went to take the knight okay i'm up
like 10 seconds
but that's why you you don't resign
especially in bullets
okay i'll go for this i might even sack
um the outside
that's not my best technique
okay this is better technique
so the issue for white is a brook's now
behind the pawn
[Music]
just have to watch out for tricky
pre-move
prevent the king from coming in
[Music]
there we go
okay okay first game
10 more to go play another london i
guess
london is kind of the bread and butter
of chess openings another one of these
i played this earlier didn't mind the
position
[Music]
not entirely sure what i'm doing here
we're going to trade everything
yeah we have a very similar structure to
earlier so i'm threatening this now with
a fork
i'll play before pawns are smiling
the queen is almost trapped actually
like here
not quite threatening g4 now
play g4 queen here
eventual idea of bishop c7 like knight
c4 bishop c7
i trapped the queen almost queen e8's
possible
uh maybe i'll win now let's take this
okay plenty of time can play this move
hitting these things
i just don't want a mouse slip like that
last game
i could have taken on f7
e6 is hanging
uh let's play that
okay that's two let's go
play sicilian oh he plays smith mora
uh i'll play one of these play a
norwegian rat
carlson went through a phase of playing
this
um this looks playable
[Music]
maybe i shouldn't have played c4 too
early but
um this bishop is now sadder than than
normal
that was a good move like when c8
so bishop moves back i have bishop h6
but what to do maybe this move
was a weird plan i just lost a pawn
i was really bad
ah okay i want to play this intake
yeah this is not my proudest game so far
that's still kind of playable
i was going to take some tricks to win
this maybe some dirtiness
trying to make things confusing
am i mating that's made in two okay
and that was that was tricky that was
very tricky i was playing english
really mixing up the openings
aha so we'll have i messed up the move
order
bishop g7 was more accurate there
okay i'll play a4 and prophylaxis
a4 is not the main line but it's i think
playable
[Music]
oh that's probably playable too
takes there's no time to think here
yeah that's just a good move
yeah all right let's play this
i'm much worse here
and i'm down on time i might lose this
would be my first loss of the match but
let's not let's be optimistic
a pawn's a bit weak there should be
three after b6
f4 that's still playable
oh okay let me down the exchange
okay there we go some hope
man i'm gonna get flagged though
uh i got flagged ah good game
okay that was unfortunate
good end game though i was too slow yeah
i played in the opening too
okay let's calm down play some more
solid chests
i should really play more kind of
controlled openings
this is a very controlled opening
um i'll go for the immediate attack
like bishop g4 bishop h3
there's 95 maybe this move
solid put the king in the corner
interesting
it should not be spending too much time
hmm
plenty of time
a c6 coming
now this and this are attacked
okay that was a nice finish okay
so 14 and a half so total and the end
should add up to 21.
i'm going to repeat that oh never mind
to remember the sign d4 and then
take some bishop d3 as well i played the
first game against sagrasha
i'll admit i don't remember this so well
but
i assume takes and c5 knight b5
i'm getting some early time advantage
see the c5 just win a piece it may have
so my rook is a bit awkward
for the queen trade
am i doing
okay looks fine very solid now
queen here i want to take in bishop's e4
there's b5
wow
oh interesting move takes
okay a funny tactic uh
i don't know how to evaluate this i just
have to move quickly
ah i was a mouse slip
don't hurt me
oh that was really dirty i feel bad but
i mean that's the nature of bullets
okay i promoted twice
oh okay so we have one of these i'll
play the bishop d6 line
this is a casa corley variation
that's a fun line
playing the style of casa i think
usually with knight f3 you're supposed
to
be more central but this is still fun
ideas kind of flow nicely
uh did i already mess up i actually
don't know because takes takes takes
f6 in the end if takes
now i defend the pawn have the bishop
pair
take queen d5
and knight is almost trapped it's not
blunder or rook
i want to play rook a2
i blundered a pawn okay i'm pulling
blender a rook and a queen
okay that was a messy sequence i think
of 94 i had bishop d5
so some form of gambit
care o'connell play a hillbilly yeah
this is a hillbilly
it's a dubious gambit but it's kind of
fun idea f3
so i'll be down upon there's some
relation to like a grand prix
attacking setup
interesting probably deep
d4 here restricting the c5
so i want to just do this stuff and and
probably it's subjectively fine for
black but in bullets
i think it's more fun to play for white
because now i can take and take on f6
oh this is gonna be fine there's a cool
mating idea
here here here here g5 queen g5 mates
opponent knows a danger
um take on
how to do this i take this way
actually don't know could have taken the
rook too
i'm sure i missed something there it was
confusing okay here i can take
takes i triple fork
good move okay threatening the triple
fork again
what just happened
okay so i'm down the pawn oh what just
happened there
wait i'm up a piece ah but i'm losing
something
i'm mating i'm meeting okay
now i'm up at rook
it's so much easier to go for the flag
here
okay i mean i could like walk the king
around but
it's hard for back to pre-move when my
rook is still on the board
i'll play g6 mix up the openings again
play one of these again
ah i don't like this
opponent's probably prepared i could
play a hippo i'll treat this as a hippo
and it's not a great hippo
i guess i'll castle and it's kind of
like a bononi
but kind of a sad bononi
like lefong's cat but lo fong's cat
seems kind of happy usually
uh e6 maybe
maybe this move
okay it's just a matter of not getting
crushed immediately
i just want to trade queens
if we trade queens i can take a deep
breath
or a sigh of relief
also we played 19 games total
so two more oh
[Music]
i thought i could take that
oh my thing all right let's take here
okay let's still
kind of playable
and there's going to be a time scramble
ah my rook
[Music]
that's funny oh no it's not funny
oh and now it's funny again no
yes oh okay it's a draw because
insufficient meeting material
oh what's that game oh we play one more
okay
yeah one more game final game i'll play
e4
oh what a match
okay so caro khan i mean my opponent's
been playing
oh sicilian i actually prepared this
last night
it's like one of the few openings i
prepared it takes in here there's a cool
idea bishop d5
there's a cool idea i think bishop c5
so casting first
i think this is all preparation oh
this is not preparation opponent
deviated
play d5 so i gave the pawn to just stop
the diagonal
okay i mean i'm trying to win this game
for the team
go chicago play this move
it's not comfortable though
this move encounter play
yeah i could move like here
okay i'm gonna be down some pawns
oh there's a funny line
[Music]
it's only made in one it might not be
easier for white to
or for black to stop it might be winning
now
i'm down three pawns but the rook can't
come back to save the the back rank
okay this is the best practical try
at the very least i'll win on time
there we go
okay hey 2700 plus two
okay so some fun games
um i i feel like i definitely had the
upper hand in some of these time
scrambles
um i feel like the score was
it didn't indicate how close a lot of
the games were
upon the outplayed me a lot and then
managed to
claw my way back but gain some rating
trying to support the team um
big thanks to the national blitz league
for
organizing this match uh
there was no adoption i don't think like
there were a few sporadic draws
i did lose that one game yeah this like
time scramble game
um but yeah we played 21 games